Venomous snakes have long held our imaginations
in thrall.
And it makes sense: to this day, humans fall
prey to their natural defenses.
Secretive, slithering, seductive, and scary,
the serpent has claimed a prominent place
in our literature, art, religion, even natural
history.
And there are few serpents more frightening
or pervasive than the king of snakes: the
mighty basilisk.
I’m sure for some of you when you see this
picture, you’ll say—oh wait, that’s
a cockatrice.
Well…you’re not wrong.
That’s right, the elusive and terrifying
snake monster and the fiery rooster monster
not only share origins, but are arguably the
same monster, just with two different names.
This , this, and this, are all the same creature.
Technically, even this little one.
But we’ll get to that cutie later.
Join me on an exploration of the basilisk-cockatrice
connection—and how it went from frightening
snake to a metaphor for pure evil.
[Monstrum intro.]
The earliest references to this serpentine
monster date back thousands of years, to the
1st century.
In his epic poem Pharsalia, the Roman poet
Marcus Annaeus Lucanus, known in English as
Lucan, introduced us to a serpent capable
of producing immense terror, writing “The
Basilisk which pours forth, hisses terrifying
all beasts, which harms before its poison
and orders the entire crowd far out of its
way and on the empty sand is king.”
With the stroke of his pen, Lucan brought
to life a terrifying snake whose royal status
was firmly established from the beginning.
So lethal, the Basilisk’s venom can kill
even after the beast has been destroyed, as
the soldier in Pharsalia learns when he stabs
the snake and the venom runs up the spear
into his hand.
In a moment of foresight, the man slices off
his own hand with a sword to save his life.
Pliny’s encyclopaedic Historia Naturalis--
or “Natural History” -- contains a similar
story, only this time both the rider and his
horse die after the basilisk is speared.
In this text, the blackish-yellow, more-than-foot-long
snake slithers along with its upper body erect,
hypnotizing its prey with eyes sunken into
a sharp head.
According to Pliny, the basilisk can kill
with its gaze alone, as well as with its noxious
breath.
Interestingly, we also learn of the monster’s
weakness—the stench of a weasel will kill
the basilisk, although the weasel too will
perish.
Pliny asserts that the basilisk earns its
Greek name, basiliskos [vasiliskos; βασιλίσκος]
and Latin equivalent basiliscus—both meaning
“kinglet”— for a crown- like white spot
on its sharp head resembling a diadem.
In fact, those two early texts -- Pharsalia
and Historia Naturalis -- laid the foundation
for the attributes that have been associated
with the basilisk ever since: that it is a
venomous snake whose breath, gaze, or even
hiss could destroy all life—animal, human,
or vegetable.
Moreover, the origin stories of the basilisk
include mention of an ability to summon other
snakes with its hiss even as it frightens
off or kills all other creatures.
It’s unsurprising then that this powerful,
decorated snake with its crown-like spot would
be subsequently called “the king of the
serpents” in the Greek poet Nicander’s
Theriaca.
Authors and artists in the Medieval period
seem to have taken liberty with the “kinglet,”
depicting the creature with a crown or even
a rooster’s comb.
Beginning in the 13th century, we find texts
describing a “reptilian monster,” and
even the “king of serpents” with all of
the traits of the basilisk plus a new one:
a rooster’s comb rather than a crown adorns
its head, and it bears a new name — the
cockatrice.
Over time we see the names “basilisk”
and the “cockatrice” used interchangeably
as the creature becomes more and more of a
snake-bird hybrid.
The cockatrice appears in literature and art,
in marginalia and coat of arms.
Bearing a combination of chicken and reptilian
features (with dragon wings or an extra head
occasionally thrown in there for good measure),
it is said to petrify with its gaze or a touch
of its beak.
With all this fantastic and suggestive imagery
around its appearance, it’s no surprise
that religions would embrace its wealth of
allegorical power.
In the Christian tradition, the serpent was
already associated with sin and the Devil,
due largely to its seductive role in the fall
of the Garden of Eden.
So the basilisk a.k.a. the cockatrice didn’t
really stand a chance.
Take for example an origin story of the basilisk
that emerged in the 1100s, which proposed
that it is born from an egg hatched by a toad.
The first person to suggest this was St. Hildegard
in her book Physica.
She even goes as far as to say it is the “diabolic
art of the ancient serpent” that comes from
“the Antichrist” that spawns this unnatural
hatching.
Over time, these dubious origins became part
of the basilisk and the cockatrice myths,
evolving even further to include details like
the egg is laid by a rooster and that it would
be incubated in a dung heap....
The basilisk became not just dangerous and
poisonous, but a literal embodiment of evil
that must be vanquished.
In fact, a lot of art from the Medieval period
shows Christ, a saint, or some other holy
figure defeating the basilisk or cockatrice.
But it can still be killed by a weasel, which
explains these absolutely delightful illustrations.
And of course, given the shift toward religious
allegory in the history of the serpent beast,
we see the power of prayer taking hold as
another defense against its evil effects.
A bit confusingly, around this time we learn
that carrying a rooster around can also protect
you—because the rooster’s crow can frighten
the basilisk to death.
Or, if you’re quick on your feet, spotting
the basilisk before it spots you, or showing
it its own reflection are among your defensive
options.
Oh yes, the idea that humans could survive
the deadly gaze of the basilisk by looking
at it in a mirror had begun to take hold.
So apparently, Harry Potter got that part
correct, even though Voldemort’s ‘basilisk’
Nagini is much, much, much larger than any
other depiction of a basilisk in literature
or art.
That’s artistic license for you!
Interestingly, the deadly gaze of the monster,
along with its more negative associations
with sin and evil in Christianity, eventually
led to its allegorical use to indicate both
“vile scoundrels” and dangerously beautiful
and seductive women in the 17th century and
beyond.
Which likely goes back to the portrayal of
Eve in the Garden of Eden, although there
many other plausible contributing factors
including the myths of Medusa and the Lamia,
along with you know—patriarchy.
John Dryden, famous English poet and playwright
of the 17th century was one such author.
The queen in The Spanish Frya, or the Double
Discovery is called the Basilisk of Torrismond
since she “kills…with her Eyes.”
But let’s go back to those early origins
of the basilisk.
There are scholars who argue that the basilisk
of ancient lore was actually a real snake
that, with time and the human imagination,
was imbued with more and more traits until
it became something utterly fantastical, and
completely divorced from its mundane roots.
If it is true, as some assert, that the early
basilisk at one point believed to be native
to Libya, this makes sense.
After all, Libya is home to the Egyptian cobra,
one of the most terrifying snakes on the planet.
Cobras are also illustrated in Egyptian hieroglyphics
with the middle of the body raised up —in
a manner that resembles bird feet, which might
have later contributed to the cockatrice interpretation
of the monster—and which calls to mind Pliny’s
description of the basilisk’s erect upper
body.
While the Egyptian cobra is a perfectly serviceable
real-life origin snake for our evil serpent,
it is not the only candidate for the honor.
Another theory?
I offer you: the humble grass snake.
The grass snake (Natrix natrix) has a yellow,
orange, or white -collar, and its defensive
mechanisms include “aggressively hissing,”
secreting a foul-smelling substance from the
anal glands, and even playing dead.
Grass snakes also happen to love to hatch
their eggs in rotting wood, plant debris,
compost, and dung heaps.
What’s most interesting about the grass-snake-as-real-basilisk
theory is that grass snakes, while totally
common, are rarely mentioned in ancient bestiaries
and early animal “encyclopedias.”
Meanwhile, the fictional basilisk is identified
as a “species” in almost every one of
these resources.
This might indicate that the grass snake was
at one point misidentified as a basilisk before
the latter’s evolution to the cockatrice
blurred the lines between reality and fiction
even more.
To make this even more interesting, the cock’s
egg origins of the basilisk-slash cockatrice
could be explained by the perfectly normal
phenomenons of hens occasionally laying yolkless
eggs or hens acting like roosters because
of a hormone imbalance or an unusually dominant
personality.
Then there’s the occasional appearance of
parasitic worms in eggs—which will sometimes
look like tiny snakes.
Whether or not the basilisk aka the cockatrice
was truly based on a real animal is unclear.
What we do know is that we humans have been
fascinated with the idea of the basilisk for
centuries.
So much so that they have permeated into our
literature and art.
To this day, the basilisk and cockatrice live
on in books, D&D, video games, and film.
And coming full circle from its vaguely reptilian
associations, there are real, modern lizards
named after this fantastic beast.
Four species of lizards, in fact.
They are in the Iguanidae family in the genus
Basiliscus, better known as casquehead lizards.
Their common names include the brown or striped
basilisk, the western basilisk, the common
basilisk, and the plumed lizard—whom you
may also recognize as the “Jesus lizards”
for their ability to run across water.
This seems particularly ironic given the basilisk’s
one-time association with the Devil.
While these lizards have no powers that allow
them to cause death with a glance, they do
have a long tail and an elongated head that
looks like a rooster’s comb.
Just another way monster history infiltrates
our real world.
The basilisk and the cockatrice have thrived
in our imaginations for a very long time.
From king of the serpents to sin incarnate
to a metaphor for the exaggerated dangers
of a woman’s allure, these serpentine/avian
monsters both fascinate and repel—their
lethal gaze lingering from the pages of antiquity
into our modern world.
Have you ever wondered what makes words, well,
words?
Otherwords, PBS’ newest show about language
and linguistics, has you covered.
Otherwords dives into languages around the
world to uncover the fascinating, unexpected,
and sometimes weird stories behind the human
trait we all take for granted.
Check out Otherwords, right here on Storied.